this program is brought to you by emory
university let me let me begin at the
outset and thanking you all for sparing
very precious afternoon knowing it's a
sunday afternoon and that you decided to
give me an hour of your valuable Sunday
I'm exceedingly grateful to you if I do
little head count I would probably in my
next life or you all one hour each want
to thank Cara and the entire Emory
University for having invited me and
giving me this wonderful opportunity of
reaching out to both my Indian friends
settled here and others who are non
Indians but decided to give a Sunday for
this cause i am in atlanta almost the
fourth time and every time i come this
one person who plays a pivotal role and
that's an yong nuo tree it is he who
every time somehow weaves a magic that I
come back here so therefore I am
personally grateful to my everlasting
friend called Annie agnihotri ivory
plenty to share with you I'm going to
focus on the anti-corruption movement
with this which we as countrymen and
women at the moment are raging and then
leave sufficient time for all of you to
interrogate me on questions you may have
in mind other than anti-corruption or
even about the movement if that is that
is acceptable is that fine because some
of you may have other issues to ask
having been away from India for so long
or others who may be curious in view of
my professional background having
ticketed the prime minister or run an
Indian prison one of the largest in the
world in numbers let me begin with this
movement on
d corruption I'm in fact pleasantly
surprised that I'm here today because
there's so much happening that I'm being
truly marked absent in Delhi and there
is a there is probably a rumor that in
Kiran has probably walked away from the
movement so I've been twittering away
I've been sending back on the facebook
saying I'm not away from the movement I
am in the movement but overseas so
therefore I am pleasantly surprised that
I could honor this commitment because
there's just plenty which is going back
and those of you who followed the news
in India would know it I've been
following it even while here through my
through my internet television cable I
have some wonderful clips for you this
presentation friends is based on my own
data which had kept in as a file of my
own called anti-corruption I did not
know that I would refer to it one day to
make a presentation but when this
opportunity came I went back to my
library and my documentation on corrupt
and on anti-corruption so therefore many
of the clips which you will see coming
is coming back from a storage or of
story of an anti-corruption as I
recorded and documented in my library
for the last year and a half so
therefore this presentation may be for
half an hour but what you see is going
to be a work which I had kept it as from
academic interest for the year and a
half this is a clip which i'm starting
with which I shot for my personal memory
of a public meeting which we held in the
north-east of India called gauhati where
Anna Hazare a addressed a large
gathering where I was a part and parcel
of the team and this is the way I like
to open something which I shot only on
my blackberry but worked for you
this is a two and a half minute clip
this is showing you the kind of rallies
we are having around the country
informing people of the anti-corruption
law which the country needs ever since
independence India did not legislate for
itself an independent Ombudsman the kind
of independent anti-corruption authority
which Scandinavian countries have which
Hong Kong has which Singapore has which
United nates States has which UK has
most of the developed countries have
India did not have Indian liberalize its
economy for the last so many decades but
along with the liberalisation of economy
did not put in place systems to check
check corruption which could flow out of
the liberalization India is getting
richer by the day economically lot of
investments are flowing but the systems
of checking corruption which can be a
fall out of that has not been put in
place and the last year and a half saw
the worst of it which is why there was
an outcry in India to have an
independent Ombudsman and this is how we
as a civil society group got together
under the leadership of Anna's array
whom you saw he is the modern-day
Gandhian in India because he follows the
principles of Gandhi ever since he was
the age of 21 he is 70 now he was known
more in Maharashtra which is a west of
Delhi he was not as much known in the
center of the center of india till he
came center stage so this is the
beginning of the story now I'm going to
show you some slides which establish
what went wrong this year and a half but
before I do that I will explain to you
to balance it to be a proud Indian what
are the strengths of Indian democracy
because the corruption has been an
aberration and I'll explain the
aberration but we've also finding
solutions to
aberration but you might ask why you're
telling me because you have a role to
play which we will come in the end what
is the role you as Indians outside India
or others who are there lessons for
others to take home from today this is
India's strengths India has an
Independent Election Commission one of
the finest independent agency look at
the number of waters it handles india
has 714 million voters thousands and
thousands of polling stations through
the electronic machine something which
even United States doesn't do it has 1
million women in ruler leadership these
are critical strengths of the Indian
democracy the Chief Election Commission
body of India is the bedrock of Indian
democracy and is is is unparalleled
anywhere in the world by which we can
ensure free and fair elections in India
look at the scale of the task which it
deals with the electorate is equal to
the entire Europe and a few countries of
North and South America in a way India's
electorate is 1163 million people who go
to what every five years this is the way
the electorate machines are transported
weed around the length and breadth of
this country there is even a polling
machine of a polling booth even for one
voter even if it is when I was making
this presentation and I spoke to my
friend mr. qureishi who's the chief
election commissioner of India he told
me that Kiran sometimes in certain areas
you have only one voter and even then a
polling station is set up for that one
voter India has an independent judiciary
the Supreme Court of India is
independent it is cannot be politically
influenced and the current Supreme Court
we've had issues in the past
but the current Supreme Court has been
one of the finest giving the finest
judgments in the recent past the cause
of his judgments some of the
billionaire's for the first time are
today in jail India has an independent
Supreme Court India has a independent
control and Auditor General it's because
of the controller and Auditor General
that most of the information about
corruption has been getting exposed it
is not politically influential and the
government is always scared of the
reports of the CAG the Comptroller and
Auditor General similarly India has the
unique independent union public service
commission which by which it selects the
top bureaucracy it's different that what
happens to the bureaucracy later but the
selection is completely on merit and
therefore has stood all the challenges
ever in the in the Supreme Court but
here begins the aberration so while
these are the strengths of Indian
democracy we've had a very serious
aberration and that is the Cobra of
corruption and this is how new the one
of the biggest strength to more
strengths India has in its democracy one
is the right to information recently
passed by the government of it by the
government by the Parliament which
entitles you to ask any information
other than which compromises the
security of state now people from left
right and center have been asking and
seeking information so has the media to
break news second aspect parallely along
with the indian strength of Indian
democracy is its free media so the free
media has been using the right to
information to pick to get information
and it got evidence to prove the Cobras
of corruption and last year and a half
we as Indians almost every evening at
primetime have been watching news of
exposed evidence and that is how the
outcry against corruption has is visible
across India so this
media reports which I am giving you the
free media which the way it reported and
leading citizens have been speaking up
on graft and lack of governance and the
media has been reporting it this is cwg
stood for the commonwealth games and
commonwealth games actually was the
beginning of the death knell it it
exposed the amount of corruption which
involved in our Commonwealth Games and
you must have read it you may have heard
it India was a host to to commonwealth
games last year but we had a very
corrupt administration fortunately for
us friends it's in the last month and a
half the chairman of the Commonwealth
Games is finally in jail but it took
almost a year of questioning from the
media and we're civil society saying why
can't he go to jail earlier till a
public interest litigation was filed and
the CAG reports were were damning and
the media evidence was evident that this
man finally went to jail because why why
he couldn't go to jail it's still a
mystery but I don't have evidence to
prove it so I'm only showing you what is
before us they were there were tickets
which were printed but never sold and
they were sold is probably went into
garbage and the stadiums were showing no
tickets available but some of the
stadiums were empty and therefore people
were asking where are the tickets there
was one police one officer of varrock
rat who had one year and 130 counts and
corruption and still in service who is
protecting him we don't know the system
this is how the media reported it was
called not economics it was c'mon Ock's
of 2010 and the one in the center the
one the person with a beard is the one
who's in jail today the one who is also
the second who is doing this who has his
hand like this is also in jail both of
them walked away with more than a
billion or two billion dollars of
corruption this is how people the media
reported or the individuals wrote it's
plundering of India
this is how the car tuned where they
showed two crocodiles fighting with each
other on the 2g talk 2g deadlock was the
spectrum sale which the one of the
minister under undersold completely
which which made the country suffer from
almost billions of dollars but in Indian
money it was one lakh sixty three
thousand crores but the Supreme Court as
I said did question the government on
black money so you've been having checks
and balances there's been a CAG which
exposed but the executive did not come
in place to send these people earlier
till the civil society movement which
I'm going to come back as I move forward
here is another woman she's the daughter
of a chief chief minister of of of camel
nod she walked away with 200 crores as
as contribution to her own television
channel which today thanks to the
Supreme Court and the media pressure and
the civil society she is in jail never
did ever in India a chief minister's
daughter see a jail if you recognize
this woman she is the chief minister of
you put the Pradesh and what is around
her is a garland of notes currency notes
these are not flowers these are currency
notes and she claims income tax reliefs
in every way by saying these are
donations from the poor people I've
talked to you about this man who's
already in jail so it said this is how
another way another form of exposure
where the grandson of Mahatma Gandhi
called Gopal Krishna Gandhi said please
save politics from the Netta's then we
had banking frauds banking secret law
which comes from the British days where
the defaulters names can be held back
and they cannot be put on website in
fact at one stage a banker's union
invited me to speak to the bankers and I
asked them that you people go on strike
at the drop of a hat sometimes why can't
you go and strike
against the secrecy laws of the bank's
why don't you demand that the defaulters
name should be up on the website the
whole country will be behind you and the
union said they would but they never did
this is about the exact amount of the
banks which keep writing off a
hard-earned money something of
repatriation I'm told that the Indians
repatriate about 60 billion dollars
every year and the 50 billion dollars
come through portfolios and stretcher
and other monies which are invested in
business but you your hard-earned money
which is about 60 billion dollars this
is how some of the money gets drained
out so you are stakeholders in this
movement against corruption now we had a
watchdog but it was without any teeth
would you be afraid of a lion without
teeth would you be afraid of a crocodile
without its jaws know we've had certain
systems in place but none of them were
given any teeth to prosecute so we had
to look I hoped in the states which had
no teeth which is only advisory and
nobody bothers about them so it's been a
systems failure mr. Narayan multi a very
respected corporate said but it's just
saying but never gets implemented but it
makes news he asks for a social audit of
the way of the outcomes of our huge
bulge earning Indian budgets but nothing
happened he said shift budget overview
to civil society for certain outcomes
but it's not happened yet maybe it will
connecting with people there's been a
disconnect between political leaders and
us we've been asking them to connect
with the people because the people are
asking for systems with teeth while the
powers that be are either wanting a weak
system or probably do it not have a
system the Prime Minister very
categorically keeps telling the
bureaucrats
which they ought to have done like
saying please visit the villages
something which is their duty to do but
still very few whether I do not know
whether its measured on what he said
whether it was implemented he said
ministers would be upgraded would be
graded every three months we have no
information about this grading we filed
a right to information and nothing comes
and the people in power which is Sonia
Gandhi and her son almost a silent the
way the way Obama comes on television
time to time the way Cameroon comes on
television time to time to explain we've
not had a political leadership coming on
the television to explain time to time
or even amongst the people the only
policy statements we hear from them is
when it's a very controlled conference
or a workshop or a seminar that is why
people are saying where are you why
aren't you speaking up so they have
these cartoons one is of the Prime
Minister the other is of Sonia Gandhi
both looking for answers so how are we
restoring public confidence here is this
example of the civil society movement
now this civil society movement is ideas
for you it's not to be left to India
alone you too can have a civil society
movement which strengthens the movement
back home as I said you reap a trait
more than 60 billion dollars plus 50
billion dollars took to your own country
of roots whether you become American
citizens or not India is written on your
face you can't go away from it therefore
here are some ideas for you but let me
share with you how we did it this is the
way we began Anna's RA and all of us
filed in a first information report
against the Commonwealth Games people
because they were not even lodging a
report to investigate so this is goes
back to November 14th last year when we
lodged a common report but this how we
began which brought in the activism of
the India Against Corruption movement
this was the beginning
of that movement you also see in the
image nahas re and Baba Ramdev Baba
Ramdev Sri Sri Ravi Shankar in all of us
joined hands together in starting this
movement this is a closer there's a
swami agnivesh also on my right on my
left and this is how rallies began we
start that's one of the rallies I showed
you that's why I began with it the kind
of rallies you saw when I began the move
that Gann this presentation we were into
these rallies where thousands and
thousands of people came on their own in
India we use technology friends we use
technology and the technology is more
than in in India available here we use
the SMS route to inform people and
thousands came on their own we didn't
have to advertise the SMS worked the
India Against Corruption website
connected people by a missed call and
once they were logged in to us we send
SMS messages so people from rural or the
urban classes children women NGOs young
men and women urban everybody came all
by themselves not one was brought all
came media decided to under under state
this this this explosion they decided to
understate and there was an outcry
against the media how could you not show
to the people of India what the people
of India want why could you how could
you hold back even when they were live
television OB vans jet on the thirtieth
of January Gandhiji's martyrdom day they
covered this thousands of rally and yet
understated it and they got a back quite
a lashing for that because it's the
first time thousands saw how media
selectively reports this is a view of
Anna who finally sat on a hunger strike
we had to Anna had to go on a hunger
fast huggles he had to sit on a
fast-unto-death the cause of two things
let me give you a little background
because of this upsurge and outcry
against corruption on one hand our prime
minister gave a international commitment
in g20
that India will sign the united nations
convention against corruption which
India had not signed ever since the
convention had been dropped written six
years ago had India signed six years ago
this convention it would have had easy
access of exchange of information
between tax havens and us till last
month they are not they had not signed
but in g20 the prime minister gave a
commitment to the international
community that they would fall in line
on anti-corruption law systems so India
had to finally sign so India did sign
grudgingly having signed the convention
they had to have domestic laws in place
and that is why they were there was a
talk about the Ombudsman now signing the
Convention and distracting an ombudsman
they brought drafted a law which was of
toothless so that means they could go
back to g20 the next year and say we
signed the convention and we have an
ombudsman international community would
not see the provisions of the law and
the law would have been toothless that
is the time when V Young's when we the
the youngsters team and us all got
together as a civil society expose the
law and said one more joke on this
country one more joke and that joke is
you finally have an embodiment without
the teeth and so what do we do we
started to draft or bill week started to
come to draft a bill and we counter
drafted the bill on the lines of Hong
Kong independent anti-corruption
Authority and in consonance with the
United Nations Convention which spares
no one which is an independent
anti-corruption authority now government
had its own bill and the government had
a civil society below we went to the
Prime Minister as a group as a group
saying we want a joint drafting
committee because you already done your
job and you cannot
except ours because you're not accepting
as you not even acknowledging it and
therefore let's have a joint drafting
committee the prime minister in that
meeting to all of us who were present
said he can't do it it's against
parliamentary practices which is not he
said it's all against conventions which
is not because they have a civil society
group which does assist them in drafting
the laws so that's a fact of the matter
but when he said no this grand old man
said all right then I have only one
resort the guardian way and the Gandhian
ways I will sit on a hunger strike till
you give me a draft but join draft that
is how of my friends this this was heard
to this and this is how under pressure
by the third day of his fast a drawn
draft request for a demand for a joint
drafting committee was a seated he sat
on a hunger fast on fifth of April and
by ninth of April the Government of
India conceded in giving the country a
joint drafting committee of which he's
one of the members and we have four
others and this is a view of the joint
drafting committee which has five of us
and five cabinet ministers from
government vidya it started to work in
the month of May and it's already a
disaster by now I'll come to that a
little later so the drafting committee
is at at work but there's been a total
conflict the drafting committee has been
saying we saying we want the prime
minister to the monthly to the Sun three
under the independent they say no we
can't keep the prime minister in the
under the under under under
investigation by independent authority
we say we want digit the judiciary under
there under the local bill which is the
local we call it the look pal which is a
moods Minh as it's known they say no we
got to keep the judges out we say we
want the entire bureaucracy they say no
only up to the joint secretary level why
do we say all because if he stopped at a
higher level of bureaucracy then how
does a common man's problem get
addressed he will have nowhere to go so
there are contentious issues
within the joint drafting committee then
we said this we need one law for the
entire country they said no the states
have to enact their own that means some
states could enact a weak law so these
are some of the then we said we want an
independent budget so that the every
time this look pal doesn't come back to
you for small approvals they said no you
have to come back for approvals so
they're very street is contentious
issues as far as today's concerned as
furs even after this presentation was
made as of today I heard on the
television yesterday that they will put
up a draft which says under sec various
sections of law sections drafted they
will say what is the cabinet ministers
view and what is the view of the civil
society so you will have two two clauses
everywhere to say this is world which is
ours this is in italics which is civil
society so people it will this kind of
draft will go to the cabinet and finally
cabinet will approve probably erase all
the italics and keep all the bold but
finally the bill will go to the
Parliament why I am Telling You this is
a vital time for the Indian diaspora
around the world millions of them have
to bombard the emails to the Prime
Minister's Office on what do you want
what does what do Indians outside India
want if you bombard them and say this is
what we expect from our Parliament to
pass we wanted truly an independent
anti-corruption authority I think it may
change the destiny of this country why
how it will change I'll wrap it up as I
move on so civil society therefore has
become a strong soft power and we are
all the time being questioned who are
you who are you your non-elected tyrants
we don't recognize you but the people
say where we elected you for us to serve
us but you stopped serving us so we
don't also recognize you so it's
becoming we don't recognize you you
don't recognize us it's becoming a tit
for tat I think Indian democracy is
coming coming of age today Indian the
water is saying
I vote for you to serve me but I want
you out if you don't serve me but I want
a role and participation in my Indian
democracy between the time i watered for
you and between the time i would gain
for you or i may vote you out so Indian
democracy is now friends coming of age
these are so an Indian Express wrote
about common man which I was telling you
about he is unseen unheard but he's part
of all these movements each one of them
was interviewed and each one of them
said I am coming here because it hurt my
self respect I want an honest India so
as I told you this is how these people
Anassa has been called the unelected
dictator this is what Gandhi ji said the
future depends on what you do today this
applies to each one of us in larger in
larger issues in this issue as well as a
larger issue the future depends on what
you do today thanks this is where we are
right now follow the news i would say i
urge you to subscribe to indian channels
so that you can switch on or go to your
computer networks and pick up the
channels and now stay abreast is going
to be a very interesting moment of
history the indian parliament is going
to debate this law look at who says what
organize yourselves into all
associations you may be sick community
you may be Gujarat community you may be
maharashtra community you may be
malayalam community you may be kerala
community please come together as Indian
community and speak in one voice go back
to the council eights and lodge place
memorandums on the Consulate's and you
can dare a bit stand outside the United
Nations and say we want India to honor
the convention which is signed in letter
and spirit just do that it will work
wonders and of course we've formed a
group can I
the paper and we formed a little website
for you all here by the way my friends
this is my younger sister Anu she's an
attorney in California immigration
lawyer now she has helped me put this
put this together called a group called
NRI AC non-resident Indians
anti-corruption n R I AC you can all
join hands in this movement there is no
hierarchy in this movement it's coming
together of people and you can raise a
collective voice and pitch yourself and
Link yourself with India Against
Corruption movement so that we can all
be together it's if if India does not
legislate the right kind of
anti-corruption bill we will have to
wait too long India loses billions of
dollars every year because of corruption
rajiv gandhi rahul gandhi both are on
record to say that out of 100 rupees
that we spend on infrastructure common
man gets only 16 rupees rest of the
money does not go into infrastructure it
goes elsewhere it is they who are on
record at different timings so friends
if we join hands together let's at least
get 90 rupees out of hundred back on
infrastructure so let's raise from 16 to
19 look at the difference it will make
to to the to the infrastructure of this
country it would have more schools more
universities more colleges more work
more vocational schools more
dispensaries and hospitals more roads
and bridges maybe penchant for old age
and clear India's debts this is what
estimates are showing that if India's
stashed money from overseas comes back
by the Parliament passing an ordinance
or law declaring overseas money as as
national wealth which can be done as Bob
Arum this demand was that declare that
as national wealth and similarly have an
independent anti-corruption authority we
as Indians will become providers for the
rest of the world we won't need any aid
we won't need anything
from the World Bank from or the IMF we
will become lenders we will become
givers not only in human resource but
even monetarily friends every voice
counts and every vote will count so
don't sit on the margins and don't think
that only Indians in India can do it
Indians overseas are wealthy you have a
voice you have an inference stand
outside the United Nations say we want
the convention to be accepted litter and
spirit and when you are there when
you're there make sure the television
covers you the NDTV covers you so that
we can see your news back home on the
Indian televisions it will absolutely
unite the guys were of the world around
millions of Indians around these people
the few elected will now know that they
have to deliver friends that is as far
as this presentation is concerned rest
of it is now left to your questions
answers whichever area you wish to thank
you very much the preceding program is
copyrighted by emory university